plane tickets gasoline groceries
inflation has hit the us hard in 2022
the consumer price index rose at its
fastest pace in more than four decades
so the cpi as it's more commonly known
is pretty much the most closely watched
indicator of inflation in the u.s and
consequently the world the consumer
price index estimates the change in
prices for a basket of goods and
services that represents the average
household spending calculations made
from that basket are used to make
decisions that affect americans all over
the country decisions about adjusting
tax brackets and benefits like social
security and food stamps and it's one of
the indexes watched by officials at the
federal reserve against the backdrop of
the rapidly evolving economic
environment our policy has been adapting
and it will continue to do so but how is
this basket selected and used to
calculate the cpi and when shaping
policy decisions why does the fed pay
the most attention to a different index
[Music]
the department in charge of the index
the bureau of labor statistics or bls
looks at several categories each given a
different importance to compute the
month's percent change some of the most
important categories are food
transportation and housing when you pull
that all together housing is a big i
mean it's the biggest expense
that we pay for out of pocket rent your
mortgage that's going to be you know a
hefty chunk more than anything else the
bls gives each category its relative
importance based on a survey of what
consumers buy keeping track of all of
those items people spend money on and
their price changes month to month is
the drop of the bls's price checkers
the agency employs over 450 workers who
track prices for up to 100 000 goods and
services and 8 000 housing units every
month based on the survey of what
consumers are purchasing to make sure
products they are price tracking haven't
changed they compare the product to a
list of data points from the month
before sometimes that list can be up to
11 pages
this process helps to ensure the cpi's
accuracy the bls is basing those
calculations off of an urban consumer
paying out of pocket the formula
excludes non-direct spending like
payments from non-profit organizations
that provide services to households
medicare and medicaid
and employer-sponsored health care plans
but again this is just an average
inflation affects different people
differently how you feel inflation
depends a lot on what's the balance
what's in your spending basket and how
that differs from the average persons as
captured in the cpi if you have to drive
to work every day you are feeling
inflation a lot more than the person who
has to take the subway because gas
prices have gone up so much and the
index doesn't include everything that's
why some like the federal reserve prefer
indexes they see as broader like the
personal consumption expenditures price
index or pce over the 12 months ended in
april
total pce prices that's personal
consumption expenditures prices rose 6.3
percent one of the reasons the fed
prefers this index is that the cpi only
transitions items in and out of the
basket every two years while the pce
changes its basket month to month based
on consumer trends the variations in how
cpi and pce are calculated mean that the
two indexes can reflect american
inflation slightly differently but the
fed takes both into account the fed's
monetary policy actions are guided by
our mandate to promote maximum
employment and stable prices for the
american people looking at multiple
indexes gives the fed a broad picture of
american inflation
cpi is undoubtedly um something that
they're watching closely especially the
month-on-month movement like that's an
important gauge of you know it does this
inflation we're seeing does it have
momentum and rising inflation of vital
items especially over long periods of
time can cause more issues like
inflation becoming embedded in the
economy we at the fed understand the
hardship that high inflation is causing
we're strongly committed to bringing
inflation back down
and we're moving expeditiously to do so
when inflation remains high for too long
consumers begin to change their behavior
in ways that can keep prices elevated so
for instance like oh my bills are
getting really expensive so i'm going to
ask for a raise and then
your boss is like people seem to be
willing to pay my higher prices so i'll
just give this person a raise and raise
my prices that keeps inflation kind of
chugging along
in a way that you know can be eventually
harmful for the economy by looking at
changes to individual categories like
housing and food consumers can learn
specific information from the overall
cpi that's going to give you a sense of
whether inflation is broadening and
that's really the concern right now for
the economy the cpi is a useful tool for
economists and consumers alike and it's
a good indicator of whether inflation
will begin to subside or whether it will
become more embedded in the economy